I want to bring in now a friend a
colleague somebody has served within the
United States Congress the former
congressman from South Carolina and I
believe a Fox News contributor trey
Gowdy I trade I really do appreciate
yourself tearing yourself out of bed we
gave you the latest possible time that
we could I was surprised that you
actually got here this early but thank
you so much for being here thank you
Jason the draft kept me up late last
night but I managed to get here by 9:30
alright so I want to get to some
politics and some stuff that's going on
in the world today because Donald Trump
he's blasting the Democrats
coronaviruses he calls it witch-hunt
here's an excerpt from the Trump
campaign email it says first the
Democrats Russia collusion delusion
failed because we fought back then their
impeachment hoax failed because we
fought back even harder now they are
trying to weaponize a new coronavirus
committee against me this is the third
witch hunt in the three in three years
if the past has taught us anything it's
that their pathetic attempts to turn the
American people against me are not going
to work I used to chair the Oversight
Committee you were the chairman of the
Oversight Committee and now they want
another committee in Congress to go
after the President and look at
coronavirus what's your take on that
well Jason let me let me phrase a little
bit differently the the president's been
under investigation since before he was
the president it's been four years now I
mean the Russian investigation began in
the spring of 2016 so for four years
Donald Trump's been under investigation
I'm gonna list for you the names of the
people leading those investigations and
I want you to stop me Jason when I get
to somebody you think is really fair and
really dispassionate Peter struck Lisa
Paige Andy McCabe Jim Comey John Brennan
Adam Schiff Jerry Nadler I mean how
would you like to be investigated by
that crew
so unfairness either the reality or the
perception of unfairness has a
devastating impact on the person who
thinks they're being treated unfairly
that's Oh Trump is watching this new
committee be formed to invest
to get his response have you seen chef
have a have a hearing on Michael
Horowitz's FISA review have you seen
chef have a hearing on China's response
to covet 19 no it's all Trump so if he
appears paranoid sometimes you can be
paranoid and people really are out to
get you well yeah it trade just like in
in January in February they were
obsessed with impeachment when they
could have otherwise been focusing or
paying attention to things that are now
affecting us now the president tweeted
this yesterday he said that do-nothing
Democrats are spending much of their
money on fake on fake ads I never said
that the corona virus is a hoax I said
that the Democrats and the way they lied
about it are hoaxes also it did start
front with one person from China and
then grew and will be a miracle and
what's your take tray on how the
president has handled this under siege
staring down the Chinese press briefings
informing the American public what's
your sense of his handling so far well
this is an unprecedented event at our
country and you know it's hard to be a
leader which is why so few people raise
their hands and say I actually want to
be the president of the United States
my advice to the president is to let the
health care professionals handle
explaining our health care response he
should be the comforter in chief he
encouraged you're in chief he should mix
in hope with with the reality of the
statistics but but let the health care
professionals handle giving us advice on
how we should treat this virus III it is
very frustrating to feel like you are
constantly the object of unfair critique
but it's been that way for for years and
I don't think he needs to punch down to
individual reporters during these White
House briefings I mean let the doctors
handle those questions be the President
of the United States that's an
incredible honor that very few people
will ever have so don't punch down to
individual reporters as tempting as it
may be well and you know you mention a
great point tre and the fact that you
know the President does like to speak
off the cuff
during those White House briefings but
that's part of the reason why he was
elected
2016 because Americans love that he
speaks to them but unfortunately he does
get a lot of criticism because he likes
to speak out loud just as dr. Brooks has
said but I just don't understand the
dichotomy of this now subcommittee
saying that they're going to investigate
the Trump administration and how they
handled this when they're criticizing
him that he needs to let medical
professionals actually handle these and
field these questions and what to do the
bottom line is this is just gonna be
more divisive than anything that's going
on right now because we're still in the
midst of copán 19 we're not past it why
don't they actually get to work and do
something and put something forward to
actually help like the small businesses
and instead of having delayed in getting
these loans out having the subcommittee
right now in my opinion is just another
waste of resources and a waste of
people's time and it's gonna take
attention away from what is really
needed right now
well dr. safar the nicest compliment I
can pay you is you would not be able to
understand the way Washington reacts
you're a health care professional who
just sees a patient and doesn't care if
it's a Republican or a Democrat just
treats the patient that's not the way
Washington works they wanted this
president under investigation since the
day of his inauguration and they want
him under investigation until the next
election and they're gonna do it and
they're gonna do it with the aiding and
the abetting of the DC media I mean
where is the scrutiny for not having
Horowitz talk about FISA abuse where is
the scrutiny for Adam Schiff not having
hearings on China and what they did with
Kovac 19 it is all Trump all the time so
if he appears to be a little bit miffed
at four years worth of investigation I
think that's the reason now congressman
I want to get your take on Vice
President Biden who has vigorously
denied the allegations of any sexual
impropriety but I got to tell you there
are a lot of people looking at this case
and saying how come the media is not
asking Joe Biden about these questions
the way they inquired with justice
Cavanaugh
well Jason Lady Justice wears a
blindfold for a reason that's probably
the last system that's universally
respected
and our culture would be the justice
system because you don't see R or D and
you don't you don't see northerner or
southerner
you just see the facts
I was really critical of politicians
during Kavanaugh I mean how could you
possibly Jason say that I'm gonna decide
who I believe before the person opens
their mouth I mean do you remember
Democrat senators say all women must be
believed well that sure is how one their
position when I was prosecuting rape
cases and they rolled the other side of
the courtroom they didn't think all
women should be believed so I I want
everybody to be treated the same Joe
Biden's entitled to due process this
complaining witness this victim is
entitled to tell her story and then we
use cross-examination and the
confrontation of witnesses that's the
way we elucidate the truth we don't do
it by saying entire category of
witnesses are to be believed or
disbelieved that's not the way the
justice system is not the way works is
not the way the political system should
work trey Gowdy smart dude we we may
disagree a little bit I'd like to see
the president smack back at these phony
reporters but I get your point and we
appreciate you joining us this morning
thank you so much Rebecca